so and thank you Michael thank you for
that very generous introduction and 21
talk about innovating for billions
billions of people billions of dollars
take your pick I was returning my my
rental car after siggraph in Anaheim
couple of years ago and i saw this very
interesting poster in this tiny Avis
office and when i saw this thing that
says have you forgotten tapes and cds
like who carries tapes and cds you know
a chucker like you did but then i
started looking more carefully I
realized that other parts other things
they're talking about that could also
disappear what should be the next thing
that least appear or already has
disappeared that you don't worry about
forgetting anymore camera camera is
almost gone what else okay so the cell
phone my disappear yeah the wall yeah
there's no reason to carry wallet keys
you know should be easy to do what about
glasses you can actually change your
displays so that the prescription is
built into them right what else why
would you need Avis when you have you
know self-driving cars that can come
pick you up and you don't have to
actually go and return a car to a
particular location what about the
poster itself so lot of things are going
to disappear and as billions of people
are coming into a new digital lifestyle
we go to run into hilarious situations
like this right and you know we live in
a very confusing world because you know
we especially merging worlds we're going
to get care without building more
hospital buildings we're going to learn
without constructing even more schools
we're going to get food without relying
on farms
and we're going to transact in
currencies that are not mandated by
governments and you know we can use the
cliche example of how we have
leapfrogged with mobile phones and
completely ditched landlines but those
kind of transformations are even more
prevalent in emerging words so what is
exciting for me is that the intersection
of emerging interfaces now the topic of
this class and the emerging worlds is
going to transform not only the
technologies and the applications was
going to transform the lives of next
five billion people and this is a
massive massive opportunity right put
some things that are bubbling up think
about the unorganized sector you know
the hawkers the street vendors you know
the unorganized regular sorry
unregulated health workers the
unregulated transportation systems
although all of them are going through a
digital innovation what can we do
through new interfaces there think about
variables right now we use variable for
productivity or wellness but variables
can be used in if the real low cost to
track attendance to improve education
systems to track epidemics if we use
them in hospitals can be used to see if
your transportation systems are
efficient if you know how people are
moving through this places and so on so
for billions of people who for them who
it'll take too long to use a mainframe
or a desktop or even a phone they could
be in a digital lifestyle by using
extremely low cost variable like a one
dollar variable what would the world
look like if you have that often we have
systems in emerging words that are been
built by governments that are not very
savvy or businesses that are that are
crumbling how can we create smart
objects that are self-organizing
self-correcting self-monitoring and that
do a much better job than top-down
systems
how can we have predictive health that
takes care of public health issues not
by relying on very highly digitized
health records or highly or we'll
understood clinical trials or
longitudinal in processes but by using
data interaction and interfaces that
people are going through you know every
day anywhere so some massive
opportunities we have in exploiting
interfaces in emerging words now in any
society the people when the fascia
problems you know they'll just tolerate
and get used to the misery there are
some people who will whine a lot and we
need them and they're people who saw you
know many people miss people I'm
guessing her in the third category and
momento dish deshpande of deshpande
foundation and you know you should
really see his read his book and and see
stalks makes a very important point he
says the progress of a given community
is dependent on the ratios of the people
in this categories and most of the world
unfortunately has people who are just
used to the misery they just tolerate
sometimes the people actually realize
the problem and start complaining about
it but very rarely do they have solvers
now this this distribution of the type
of people really challenges the way we
think about how to solve problems I mean
if you are in Boston occur in bay area
you have probably more solvers then then
then you really want and and they're
going to work on things that are not
very important but eventually they'll
get to the things that matter and
they'll they'll kind of sleep through
all the problems that matter and the
society moves forward but in the
emerging world you don't have that that
luxury you have very few people for
solvers and the solvers may not even
have the resources so we cannot copy
paste the models that we have for
innovation for for execution for for
startups from tripping or ship for
venture the smalls that we have in canva
for solver rich world are very different
then there would be somewhere else
because if you just have the same models
for innovation and entrepreneurship and
funding you will see copycats of you
know taxi hailing services productivity
services and and so on and we have to
kind of break break through this
challenge and realize that the
distribution is very different and in
fact count with a completely inverted
model of how we would do innovation how
would we solve massive problems and how
would we actually empower them to go
ahead and solve them an anomaly we are
here at Stanford you know Addie school I
were just talking into a James earlier
about his class on grand challenges and
you know the extreme affordability class
I think they were lucky at the media lab
or at MIT or Stanford where we have
these resources but is that just a few
dozen few hundred people going through
the system we need hundreds of the
thousands of solvers to go out there and
get that going so I'm soph my colleagues
at the Media Lab have started a new
initiative called emerging words and
going beyond you know big data Internet
of Things and thinking about newly
digital citizens we are thinking about
how can we leapfrog and unleash the
potential of thousands and thousands of
solvers and one case study that I will
go through a little bit later is a is a
open conurbation center that we have
just outside Mumbai and let I'll tell
you what it's not it's not being done
through contests it's not price ology
it's not being done through hackathon
which is community building it's not a
degree program it's not an incubator
because we are not talking about
entrepreneurship and startups yet and
it's not a corporate center right and
I'll tell you what it is this
it's not okay so when it comes to
interfaces let's go through a few
examples of how we are stuck in our
thinking you know here is a a slit lamp
which you know to look for cataracts
cloudiness in your lens and this device
hasn't really changed in many many years
you know his health worker working on my
eye and here is the nurse taking picture
of my retina back of my eye and I'm sure
many of you have done this you know the
first time she doesn't get the picture
right you know what does she do do it
again right she's going to try it again
but you know she's going to use her left
hand as a most moist mouse pointer with
my head as the mouse and then stitch is
going to shove it hopefully you know my
eyes are lined with the eyepiece right
this time and then take a picture now
this is a quarter-million-dollar device
and look at its interface so this is
very problematic and to get prescription
for glasses you know lost enough or
after and you can write her in a top
song about it but you know for millions
of millions of people out there in the
world they're stuck and they're not
getting the services because the
interfaces are horrible so a few years
ago we created this solution call I
netra which is a mobile phone you snap
into binoculars you look through it and
I'll play a video game for about 30
seconds and you get prescription for
your eyeglasses your nearsightedness
farsightedness and astigmatism and the
idea there is really exploiting the
interface so you know if you typically
do this exam I doctor's office their
shine lasers into your eye and you know
you're just sitting there and things are
being measured on you or just asking you
really dumb questions like a or b in
things like that they are not letting
you control anything they're not giving
you the power to actually solve the
problem for yourself but here here you
can and the reason why this was possible
is you know few years ago we heard about
this so-called retina display
right extremely high resolution they
didn't realize that we can she'll use it
to test the ice test the retinas you
know a typical high high-end medical
device would shine a laser at the back
of your eye and effectively create a
beacon shining spot at the back of your
eye and they look at the light that's
reflected from that you know from that
from that spot and if everything is fine
with your eye the so-called shock
hertman wavefront sensor principle
through a microlens array very much like
a light field camera that you might you
know lytro came out of here so you might
be familiar and it creates dots at the
center of this microlens arrays and you
see this uniform dots but if you have an
aberrated I if you have you know a
stigmatism or nearsightedness then
actually those rays don't come out
parallel and the wave fronts are
distorted and so the spots on the sensor
get get displaced and the displacement
is proportional to the local slope of
the wavefront and you can just solve the
to deepen equation to reconstruct you
know the curvature of the distortion
that's how you would prescribe glasses
or contact lenses this is a great
principle but again very expensive
shining lasers very high you know high
precision sensors and so on can we do
this on a mobile phone so we going to
just do the thing exactly reverse we go
to share we're going to create a display
with area of dots and put a microlens
array in comes in front of the display
if you were perfectly normal I all those
points will converge to a single point
so again on the screen you're going to
show area of dots what you will perceive
is a single dot but if you have a
distortion in your eye and you showed
the dots at the center this uniform area
of dots will actually look like a jumble
collection of dots okay everybody got
that and what we can do it in software
is manually shift those dots pre distort
them so that by disturbing those doors
you will perceive it back down two dots
it's like a video game you're playing
you're moving the things around till you
see a single dot and this turns out
is sufficient to get prescription for
glasses even better than today's medical
devices because you're doing this
process yourself as opposed to letting a
device that's you know taking
measurements for your blinking your eye
while you're thinking about your next
vacation and and you know kind of fading
away things like that so the power of
interaction is very very powerful hero
right and it's not just about you know
blurry vision in a children don't go to
school because they can't see well you
know signalling this thermometer for an
eye or you know elderly cannot do the
job that leads to illiteracy sorry
unemployment and and and and lack of
income and then you know sometimes you
just want to watch you know your your
soccer match in high def right it this
thing's really matter to various people
so we spun out this company a few years
ago and what's interesting from hco
point of view is that now you would just
described it as a oculus VR headset that
can do prescription for glasses right
because that's what it is snap the phone
you know in a in a binocular and it's
going in the reverse where the VR
companies are working with this startup
saying about half the people who you
know what other people in the world have
prescription frames and they cannot
experience or enjoy vr the same way as
everybody else because the moment you
put on your prescription frames you're
you're you're messing with optics of the
rest of the linksys your field of view
your optical alignment between the three
lenses your lens of the eye lens of the
eye glasses and the lens of the VR
display all need to be nursing the line
and that cannot be achieved so it
relates to a lot of challenges going
forward so now you know now we are back
to that CR problem of virtual reality
augmented reality of how do we change
the prescription inserts in this
interface devices so that you don't have
to wear prescription lens lens
anymore okay what about looking at the
back of the eye right back at the retina
so for this we use the technique that we
are all familiar with which is taking
selfies right now why can you take
selfies today and you couldn't take
selfies with point-and-shoot cameras
what's the reason size is one but point
to shoot camera is also pretty but it is
simple dining this display the display
the feedback the fact that I can see
myself makes it very very easy to decide
if it's a good picture otherwise I'm
going to guess all the time keep taking
pictures till I get one right so why
can't we use the same principle for for
other complicated devices out there what
if instead of having the nurse shove my
head into this eyepiece what if I can
see myself what's going on and just give
me a cue of how should i align my eye so
that there'll be a good selfie of my
retina that's exactly what we did in
order graph paper and then we have a
light-filled display that allows you to
look through it and when you can see the
display the camera can see you so if I
can see you you can see me using the
principle and some other things you can
create devices that can take pictures
back of your eye and now imagine you
wake up in the morning and you brush
your teeth you know you do an I selfie
if you're healthy if you have a
condition or your you know prone to
something specific data goes in the
cloud we can do longitudinal analysis we
can do cross-sectional analysis for
ethnicities or geographical region
lifestyles and now we can really start
talking about how interfaces and end
data mining can come together there was
a question here here opportunities like
you said you like have this inside
without a camera in a smartphone then
did you take that inside and just think
of anything that you couldn't you use
found out about this this retina scanner
thing or yeah I mean it doesn't match
making going on right you're you have a
bag of tricks that you keep in mind you
know next time you take a selfie you
have to release ask this question like
why is this possible now and wasn't
possible before and then you realize
okay this is the two tricks you know one
is kind of you know it's a simpler
device you know it's thinner and second
is that you can see yourself the
feedback and then you have those bags of
tricks with you and then when you run
into problems hopefully run into
impressive problems not own the problems
that you face on a day-to-day basis and
then you do a matchmaking right but I
mean it's the kind of a process of of
you know solving problems versus having
solutions and finding problems to solve
right so you kind of go back and forth
between that and and then you know we
have other interfaces where you can just
drag and drop your selfies into a web
browser and it will take care of all
this calculation so it's gonna be have a
kind of API in a web browser so we know
I and my group had doesn't serve this
ideas of here we can change this we can
use interface principle you know we can
use this other principle and we can
solve all these problems in in in I
diagnostics I care solutions for the
blind and so on and it doesn't I mean at
the Media Lab I'm sure the same thing
here you know this is my group everybody
has a 3d printer we have access to in
all the things but let's do the world
doesn't look like this right where these
problems actually are more prevalent and
you know for good or bad major the
problems that we want to solve are
actually not in Palo Alto or Cambridge
there's somewhere else in the next five
billion people that we want to impact
are not here so where to go out there
and find those problems and how bag of
our tricks bag of our solutions to see
where it varied matches so we created
this platform called red X rethinking
engineering design and execution and we
came up with a process that in the
beginning was very
very inefficient and very time consuming
but as I will tell you over time it has
become a very well oiled process and the
strategy was we had a bunch of ideas
sitting in Cambridge we we approached
all the major eye hospitals and and
Perkins school for the blind and Messiah
near and new england college of
optometry we brought all the experts
together and said is this important and
then we went to LV Prasad Eye Institute
which is the largest Institute in India
and they had their experts and we got
together and we say what are some
important problems that she was solved
and we made a list and my team and
others had some solutions of how we
could do it together but you know if I
did that in my group at one master
student or 1 p-ish is 200 a time it
would take us years and years to get
that out right maybe 20 years to get
that out there is no point waiting so we
bought a whole bunch of people together
of course interviewed them in a found
the right partners and just unleash them
with some some initial concepts of how
we can solve in a problems for the blind
problems for low vision you know
problems for for cataracts problems for
lazy eye and so on and here's a quick
movie that can summarize this this
efforts and this is audio
you
and then these iterations are very tight
we have all the key players in same
place the innovators the patients the
doctors
and so this process was interesting
because we made rapid progress you know
we raised a lot of cash you know
donation my foundation money started
pouring in we appoint a new center and
matter of three months we're up and
running and in the last three years the
center has produced all kinds of
solutions for neonatal care two
solutions for mapping in a spread of I
conditions I mean every piece of the I
pasol is being looked at and now of
course Center is getting lot of requests
to look at virtual reality and augmented
reality as well it's kind of fun so that
was interesting and it's going very well
so we said let's expand that a little
bit and look at health in general
because kind of health and education
environment is a massive topics when it
comes to when it comes to impact if you
start looking at kind of oral health and
oral cancer you know sleep disorders or
you know you know challenges of the
hearing and so on and it's been kind of
an interesting process and many of these
things are coming out many of them fail
of course like like anything else and
and then we have this series of efforts
that continue to grow now in all these
efforts I would say the principle is
straightforward I mean if you think
about health we train the doctors really
well first and they use crappy
instruments and then over time we made
the instruments really really smart so
the doctors can use them sometimes their
instruments do such a good job that we
don't even need highly trained doctors
we can use you know healthcare workers
but the one piece in a medical visit or
a hospital that's completely under used
is the patient we do not expect any
intelligence in that patient we treat
the patient as a vegetable this is
very disappointing if you're thinking
about HCR right so what can we do to
change this basic mindset and actually
allow the patients no I'm just I'm not
just talking about you know patient as a
consumer but patient as a producer of
ideas of interaction and trails and you
know we all like AI but I a beats a I
you know intelligence amplification
beats a I so let's have people in the
loop and see how far we can go so using
this principle my group and my art
classes have looked at every aspect of
of health tech solutions you know for
for eyes for four years for infectious
conditions under the skin skin perfusion
oral imaging teeth looking at infections
microfluidics diagnostic solutions beds
sleep apnea sensors hydration tremor you
know a whole bunch of them right new
types of new types of stethoscopes and
so on and and you know we are coming at
this mainly from a a interface
technology point of view to solve this
problems she's been a great journey now
another thing I want to tell you about
emerging words is that you know in the
80s and before it was about saving lives
you know how can we send vaccines and
how can we send mosquito nets and and so
on and then over the last 10 or 20 years
the world has changed and we started
saying oh no those emerging words are
real actually emerging markets of
billions of people we can sell them
products so what can we do in emerging
markets in a very exploitative but I
think we're in a third phase now where
you can think of emerging words are
actually partners in co-innovation if
you really want to solve those problems
so you know we took the next challenge
which is this festival called kumbha
mela and about 30 million people show up
in
it is very close to Mumbai and so very
colourful festival very colorful very
exciting a lot of passion it goes on for
over a month we're not highly highly
recommend it you know if you don't
burning man this is this is the next
next one it's it's I was right in the
middle of it very very exciting but you
know as beautiful and as kind of
spiritual as it is it has a lot of
issues you know I mean we have a city of
New York appearing and disappearing in a
matter of a month right health housing
payments all these challenges so our MIT
team started working about two years in
advance before the actual festival which
was August of 2015 about seven months
ago and two years before that we started
working with the city government with
local education institutions and a lot
of corporate partners and we serve very
kind of intervene and do something
something exciting and we looked at you
know some very specific verticals you
know it's a massive operation there's
not much we can do and you know we
looked at foot tracks that can count
people we looked at food distribution
networks looked at traffic jams we'll
look at real-time maps that can be
created out there look at pop up housing
methods we looked at logistics behind a
lot of these distributions
we did epidemics by using clever forms
you know having lot of manpower on the
ground crowd steering and so on a
probably the most important thing we did
was we brought a culture of innovation
to this you know hundreds of years of
old festival and worked very closely
with the government and local businesses
and here's an example of you know
typically the crowds will be managed
through you know walkie-talkies or
barricades and so on and we use actually
cell phone tower data to see how things
are moving so this is kind of the the
riverbed that you saw that's where the
crowds are growing as the morning
progresses is the day of the festival
one of the important days and here's
where all the shadows and although
although although the priests are so you
can see them moving around a lot of
people are visiting his the railway
station down here you can see people are
arriving the railway station this is the
outer parking lot a lot of people are
being dropped off and there to walk this
whole distance which is about seven to
ten kilometers our control room was
right here we were all sitting here but
of course I would make the trips and so
these were all expected the train
station drop of things like that but you
know this redspot is interesting so you
know the day was very busy then I've got
a call from the city commissioner and
the police commissioner we went and
we're talking to them continuously right
and they said we have to figure out
what's going on where people are going
and why is taking them so long and we
showed this pot to them and actually the
reason why it's so close to me is
because I was stuck here so we woke up
at I know 3 a.m. in the morning we did
the trek we stayed there and about 1pm
we thought we should start coming back
to look at our data some more and start
making the phone calls and all these
other things but I got stuck in this
this circle here for a couple of hours
and that's because the way they had
cordoned off the one-way streets was
actually very problematic and so we
shared with them and we had a lot of
discussion but is that the kind of
things we could do in near real-time of
course this data is being transmitted to
the control room and all sort of certain
individuals in so on so it was very
exciting across various sectors and then
invite invited the whole
city team you know the mayor the deputy
mayor the City Commission or the police
commissioner and and and you know all
the key leaders to MIT and we spent a
week after everything was over and we
had some free time to kind of exchange
ideas and what can be what can be done
and through that interaction this was
just an October about six months ago
through the interaction actually we were
able to spin out this whole emerging
world's effort that I am talking about
and we had some great corporate partners
and now we have a a multi-million dollar
co innovation center that's been set up
in this clear to city of nashik outside
Mumbai just in a matter of six months as
I said it's not a contest because if you
do a prize then in places that are not
solver rich all the people who have
nothing else to do will actually
participate in those contests not the
people who are highly trained and highly
motivated it's not a hackathon because
hackathons will bring the communities
together but they don't have tools to
follow up after they leave the place it
could not be a degree program because of
the the incentives for a degree are very
different than incentives for solving a
massive problem and doing innovation
entrepreneurship it's not an incubator
accelerator because the problems then
sirs are are are are not completely well
defined the teams don't want to think
about their business plan or impact plan
right away and the teams also don't
decide amongst themselves you know who's
the CEO who's the CTO and how much
equally do they have even before they
have started working on it right and so
also not a cop corporate innovation
center because we actually don't know in
the beginning what exactly the model
would be but is the important problems
nevertheless so the way it works is we
have grand challenges that I will escape
few of them and then we have a one-year
internship program where this innovates
anymore anyone anyone of you can apply
anywhere in the world and they have a
one-year internship program that part of
the time is in at this center called
disc digital impact Square and part of
the time is that MIT but only a small
fraction of that will come to MIT most
of them is actually
a in disc and then we have a great
founding partner which is TC estar con
solution versus largest software company
in india and and we going through these
cycles right and the next event is
second week of july if anybody wants to
come so it's it's a beautiful center
looks little bit like media lab and the
colors Sean if you're here can project
recognize this place and you know it
looks great so that's fine i mean place
is easy money is easy but what about the
problems and what about the people right
so here are a few things i'll just give
you a flavor of some of the kind of
problems we are looking at and would
love to have a discussion with you so
how can we build a cat scan machine that
fits in a rickshaw or a tuk-tuk now the
reason why this is is not possible is
because a typical cat scan machine has
15 g of acceleration ok because you are
things spinning and then you have this
mechanical mass of accelerometers next
detectors that are moving as well which
means we have to solve this key problem
of a system that does not have
mechanical motion at all right and the
second is some of the most extensive
component of of a cat scan or x-ray
machine is how you do transfer the x-ray
image into an optical image using
scintillators that part is very very
expensive so we are looking at following
these two key aspects of the problem and
as you if you follow a lot of the work
on our website an hour on a group page
you will see the kind of papers
republishing towards this goal into
stock i'm mainly going to tell you kind
of grand challenges i won't go into the
algorithmic aspects of it or how we are
solving what happy to have the
conversation separately or it can go on
the website everyone a she yeah it's
pretty to re-define pretty broadly
defined and all the year you may find it
more and more
absolutely acquire this bob necessary
yeah and then you don't reap reaches you
you know you apply to be in the program
and and you know kind of specified two
or three challenges that you think are
exciting and they kind of go through
this go through this process we talked
about how can we put prescription on the
display because you know it's much
cheaper to create connected displays
than worried about spreading a 300
million people in India need glasses but
don't wear them so think about education
think of it employment all those
challenges and is actually work with
Gordon wis design whose faculty here at
EE you know we have so many great so
much great information in archives in
books but we cannot open them because
they're too fragile so imagine if you
can read through a book without opening
the book page by page and we're solving
that you cannot use x-rays you cannot
use optical wavelengths they solving
that by using terahertz which are about
100 micrometers or more in in wavelength
close to 100 micrometer and and and a
millimeter let's keep all this video but
you know here you have can the outlines
of this pages and the terahertz
unfortunately penetrates so well through
the paper that it it to it to terahertz
it looks like piece of glass so the
contrast between ink and paper is going
to be minimal and the only reflection
you're going to get is because of
criminal referral reflections because
the change in refractive index of the
ink and paper but then also have air in
between the strap and that destroys our
arles degrades your signal we going to
get reflections from the air gap as well
then whenever Sato and rohan puri also
from a group are working on how can we
use bioimpedance a bio impedance
tomography to do interactions without
entering a password because password is
very challenging for for many tasks
in emerging words and so using a bio
impedance tomography at multiple
frequencies to do soft authentication
and they also have a start up in this
space 3d displays are great but can you
create glasses-free 3d displays and so
this is matt Hersh another spin out from
my groups in this case these things are
already out there creating this
glasses-free 3d displays not blazing
lenticular or diffractive techniques but
by using a series of techniques we have
published in siggraph papers over the
last few years that use to to
effectively random-dot stereograms that
are placed very close to each other and
how can you interact without cameras in
in a private setting so you could be in
a in a bathroom but also it could be the
hospital or places like that very remote
put cameras and it can interact with
that and we are doing that with radio
frequencies a lot of work at u-dub and
and Dina katabi is group at at MIT has
also looked at this and so radio
frequencies are becoming you know
another powerful tool for interaction so
in this case we can do a time-of-flight
measurement through wall of human bodies
in this case it's a mannequin the static
and there's a time-of-flight movie at
picosecond resolution of how things are
going through so you you know the energy
hits the head and the torso and
shoulders and it call comes back when
you aggregate that we can create very
approximate 3d shapes of what's around
the corner how can you look at
circulating tumor cells in a device that
looks like a blood pressure cuff and
here we're using the principle of
fluorescence lifetime imaging this still
pretty far out of how can you measure
the lifetime of fluorophores through
scattering media and how can you do oral
imaging without x-rays in this case we
are using the concept of an optical
brush a toothbrush where the where the
brush is made up
of optical fibers and by sending light
through the optical fibers without
knowing the actual position of the fiber
ends we can create 3d images of what's
at the tip we are able to create the
intensity images what's at the tip of
those fibers what about creating global
scale information how can we do
sentiment analysis at street level at
the block level that's accurate at a
global scale so this is by a nickel Naik
in our group in collaboration with
Professor Hidalgo also at the Media Lab
and here we can create maps of New York
City's cities like New York City or
Boston or Philadelphia where every green
dot represents a place where people feel
it's safe and a red dot is where people
feel it's not safe and all this
sentiment is actually computed using
Google Street view images so there's
some crowdsourcing where we have a pair
of images that are being shown and for
few tens of thousands of such images we
can lower the descriptors the
classifiers and then we can apply that
at City scale and so tools like this are
very important in emerging countries
because the governments and
organizations are not well equipped to
do large-scale service and figure out
what the what the challenges are how
interesting things are you know what
should be done for beautification what
the income levels are but logs
information actually gleaned from from
just imagery when of course its
controversial if you live in a green dot
area it's good if you're in a red dot
area you know you should have you should
be the complainer you should wine and
then go back to the city so this can
create those tools so this comes to this
brings up another point as an academic
about how this work kind of plays out
everyone knows about you know kind of
publish or perish and the way the reason
we did that is because the only way we
could have an impact as an academic was
to publish and let rest of the world
take our ideas forward but then the
world changed and we have
you know good rapid prototyping tools we
have access to in all kinds of resources
now actually build a demo I show it
working on 5 10 20 people and the demo
is your proof that what you have your
invention your innovation your
hypothesis is actually true so now we
are in the demo demo or die kind of mode
but I think entering a third phase which
is deploy or disappear because the
barriers to actually deploy your ideas I
also come down yeah of course our
crowdfunding you know you have abilities
to work with partners all over the world
we have literally easy access to all
kinds of awards that give you additional
cash and it's also easy to collaborate
with partners all over the world online
there is no excuse not to deploy and so
I think we are where as even as an
academic we can't just stop at
publishing we definitely had to deploy
so you know a twist and Kai actually
they're massive demo sessions right and
your Xperia mode if you think it's
really good quality work but I think
going to enter the third phase very soon
all right so in the last part of my talk
let me jump through a few challenges
that are bubbling up just as a part of a
conversation here and these are created
by artists at digital impact square
which we just got up and running as I
said in the last two to three months
right and the first course already there
so you would imagine a public
transportation is a big problem but
actually in tier 2 cities more than half
the public transport is running empty ok
and you can play take your guesses of
why that is you know the feeders are not
right and then syntheses are not right
you know the their overt populated sorry
overcrowded in times that really matter
and and so on right but there's no way
to figure this out there's no way to
create a blueprint of this is how these
things should be changed so imagine if
you can solve that you know parking is
not just a Palo Alto problem is global
and remember in emerging countries
parking place of very big role in in
informal transportation as well
large vehicles are actually unregulated
but transporting people so we had to
solve this problem to get people flows
crime and police is a very sensitive
topic and so in the in the disk center
the way the teams are working is they
actually spend time with the police
commissioner they shadow him to lot of
meetings they go on the nice night
rounds within the police chief's they
actually have access to the prosecutors
so they're spending time talk about need
finding that actually spending time in
this resources this this would be
impossible as an academic or a start-up
or even a corporate entity to go figure
this out we know this is a multi-billion
dollar opportunity that can touch a
billion lives but to do that they have
no the framework but here we have
integrated eco system of government
officials businesses and and everything
is laid out so even if have one week and
you want to go and figure these things
out you can jump in and you know
everything is everything is planned for
so the teams are having a lot of fun and
they're sharing their nodes in a public
domain if you just go to the website on
the Facebook page you will see what what
what problems that identifying right now
that are worth working on you know
institutional delivery is is is very
critical you know a large fraction of
our births are taking place in informal
settings that as you can imagine creates
all kinds of health challenges so you
know the rich world solution would be
less make sure there's a hundred percent
institutional delivery a more clever
solution would be saying now let's go
after this unregulated Asha workers who
are actually the delivery anyway and see
how we can empower them to do a better
job right so there's a trade-off between
try to make everything very modular and
clean and and you know the way it is
here in the ritual and this you know
this this plays a role I mean if you
take about this predictive model for
health you know there's health records
how we're going to get the health
records you know because the the doctors
are all worked
do not know how to manage their software
systems people have mobile phones people
have prescriptions here on the hand peep
is the paper can we create smart
solutions that don't rely on healthy I
mean even the u.s. if you go from one
hospital to another you have to carry
your physical health records so just
imagine situation at at other places
fisheries you know real-time information
can can can change that food cattle you
know hawkers nasty problems where we
have tens of millions of people in each
of these professions so let's jump in
this a little bit okay so think about
the problem with this unorganized sector
of the economy which is hawkers and
street vendors and you've seen this in
many countries right now the first
problem you would tackle is just hard to
identify who they are right that's not
very good i mean it might increase their
visibility and bring them into a system
but maybe they don't want to do it
because if they get identified there
will be in the tax net and they'll have
to be relative you know satisfy all the
regulatory constraints you might say hey
listen maybe i want to create a
peer-to-peer communication and
collaboration between this this street
vendors and hawkers because they can
share best practices and have collective
intelligence collective bargaining but
they might say you know what we had a
lot of trade secrets already know my
cousin who does a good job for me and i
already know my friend who's been
helping me i don't want to be working
with people I don't know why should I
share with them what I know where I get
my sources from and how to keep the
police happy you and they might come and
stop my business or how might go find my
customers you might think they should be
given some kind of integrated software
for transactions and tracking and then
would say you know what I don't have
time to deal with my customers you know
and enter something in my in my phone or
a tablet in a software because cash is
very easy I can do parallel transactions
with five people while they're waiting
for me you might say why not create you
know kind of purification share economy
create a logistic layer and they would
say you know what V every
every every minute matters every rupee
matters for us and we just don't have
time we cannot afford a more
sophisticated solution right so things
that may seem pretty straightforward you
know identity communication logistics
actually don't work it's a huge
challenge so to conclude yeah I mean
these challenges are interesting whether
it's you know innovations for an
organized sector whether how to build
smart objects that overcome systems you
know what can we do with one dollar
variables how can reproductive health
how can we scammers for good these are
all interesting problems but I'm sure
many of you are just like I am often
concerned of where do I even start you
know will I create something that should
actually make a difference so those of
you who we know we're old enough in the
80s probably remember this situation the
best use of a pencil was to remember
this to revive the tape when it doesn't
you know it gets gets tied up so you
could never know how an invention will
be used in what scenario it's more
important to just keep creating new
ideas new solutions because you don't
how they will use and so this woman just
outside Hyderabad in India you know one
of our team members to this picture and
you know she's she's an entrepreneur
she's taken a technology that we use
very casually which is a weighing scale
and she has converted that into a micro
business for herself right so people
come in and they pay you know ten cents
or twenty cents and just get there wit
right but she's so proud she even has a
welcome mat for her business you know so
I think the message for the you know the
lesson I have learned is it's more
important for us to make an effort to
solve these problems whether we succeed
or not because as long as we're creating
something that's
impactful powerful there are other micro
entrepreneurs that we can empower will
go and take these solutions and bring
bring it to scale in unimaginable ways
so next time you see this sign and
you're chuckling like what is this think
about the other leapfrogs going on in
education in health in transactions in
transportation in rest of the world and
how they're overcoming the barriers that
we have faced here for last 23 years and
I'm just skipping it altogether and
getting into a new world so you know
whether you are at home or at work or at
play you're the factory floor or a
grocery store I think interfaces in the
emerging words have a huge role to play
thank you image for questions and
comments yes James so curious about the
point that you made and a bball so
there's been if you love are making
about deployment it's something that you
know I can't leave in and some of my
research button it's really far right
and I've had a better chance of doing it
when I've had your organization so when
I ran a research lab for and felt I had
a lot of money that I could spend on the
format when I'm a faculty member you
know in a group of graduate students who
want to actually graduate in six seven
years um it's much harder to think about
doing any new deployments where you have
to support things or get the quality to
a level that's closely from our short
i'm wondering you know what tricks and
tips every bar yeah do that make it fit
with academic hall word so it's not a
job yeah so i think i think the question
is really is you know how do you deal
with this tension between to search an
impact you know and especially resources
for the two
and as I said for me as an academic it's
becoming more and more challenging to
think in the in the quanta of one
masters of one PhD and starting the
world is going to change I think the
whole economic structure of getting
degrees is going to change everything
right now we might be okay but I think
this whole notion that an individual
should work solo on a project for
multiple years is crumbling down I think
rest of the world has move towards a
multi-person team going through worse
for filtrations and doing a whole bunch
of things towards the given goal and I
think that aspect has to come to
academia as well as about your other
point about about you know when you have
a integrated ecosystem things can happen
much faster like the Intel that you ran
in Washington that's absolutely true so
you know as I said initially when we
were doing this it was very inefficient
we'd have to spend a lot of time on the
ground now we're doing something similar
in Guadalajara in Mexico also in Central
Europe so we are expanding this through
MIT and it's very inefficient in the
beginning but the but the beauty for any
front of you in the room is now
everything is set up so now it's very
easy for you to go for a week for a
month for a year and then everything's
ready to go on day one you have the
resources you have all the relationships
with the government the business leaders
with hospitals with tax union who are
you care about it's all set up and then
you have people like this innovators who
are in their internship program we're
going to work on those concepts as well
right so actually I'm spending I'm on
sabbatical right now from MIT and
spending time in Palo Alto so we'd love
to meet you for coffee or a drink and I
was putting some special projects at
Facebook and so you know anybody wants
to apply for internships or come work
with us at Facebook please talk to your
advisor and let us know and and that's
an example where many organizations now
are realizing that instead of doing
something in a completely controlled
setting inside a corporate center or
academic institution it's actually much
better to do in an open co-innovation
system and it seems straightforward
pretty obvious
but people don't know where to start and
I believe we have a at least the
beginning of a path where it can be done
in a very quickly and you can do
academic research as well why is one
year things are you inviting yes I'm
really opened up the fact that we have
those hundreds of people coming through
about 400 people in one year coming
through internships is just a piece of
the puzzle but anybody in the world can
come and spend times there yes the
beginning you mentioned the problem that
they may be a large number of solvers
just in certain areas yeah but
eventually they hold it on the problems
that do so my question is do you think
that is there are significant challenges
in the need filing process and if any
what kind of improvements do you think
can be made specific to that that area
the need finding process yeah they can
have accelerate connecting solvers to
problems yeah i mean i mean this good is
in a well known for the need finding
process is absolutely important but
often it's the challenge of out of sight
out of mind you have to be really there
to actually understand what's going on
but that's just one aspect of it if
you're there by yourself you know making
phone calls and showing up it's not
going to go anywhere you need an
integrated ecosystem of fellow solvers
who have done some background work for
you or fellow complainers who have kind
of codified or made formal their
complaints what they don't like about it
and only once they have done that you
can go in and do something about it it's
very difficult for individual or even a
small organization to go start this
thing from scratch so I was just having
conversation with James earlier about
you know how long it takes to do the
need finding and I think that process to
change because we need these outposts to
actually shorten that process and it's
the same problem with you know all the
startups you know here in bay area or
Boston is that many of them are working
on problems that are not important but
you want to get started and maybe the
second or third startup is where that
she going to make an impact but more
important get started then then be
you know getting used to the misery or
be complainers yes so I have a diploma
related question I gonna start up where
we are focused on helping farmers get
crop insurance using you know satellite
imagery right working in a bar in here
yeah question is as a start-up speed is
what startup is about right working with
government and all the big body is a
pretty slow which could eventually which
could possibly kill us yes how do we
manage that and you know any thought
process yeah that's exactly the problem
right if you if you are educated can you
cannot do research if your startup just
start for resources if you are corporate
people look at you in a suspicious way
our government you know you don't how
your act together so who's going to
solve it who's going to solve it and
that's why we need this integrated
integrated ecosystems so you know if you
come tomorrow to our you know disc
center or the emerging world center and
say hey this is the problem you want to
solve boom all the resources will be
lined up and you know there's it's not
incubator accelerator so there is no six
percent you know 120k no common stock
none of that stuff and it can just make
it happen so i think i think you know
that's the that's the power of possible
making it happen I mean we haven't
proven mega-success yet it's all in
Boston sports in I care and health and
and you know crowd festival Soviet you
know of proof points are not massive but
there are some proof points along the
way that it seems to work there yeah
question about do you feel there is a
tension between service innovation and
product innovation because I actually
work for Intel and did a front end in
the market side and there were some
products are were deployed to the market
but they died after like a year or two
because there's not a service that's
enforce them yeah yeah and you can put
products and create demos and even
deploy them as hard as he might be but
then sustaining them over time it
doesn't depend on the private anymore
depends on the whole ecosystem but
absolutely consistent events on a
service right a process that has to be
robust and it has to be in Amity yeah do
you feel that I mean there's enough you
know Rosie's on the whole process not
just the products like absolutely night
there's too much emphasis on it I mean
it's always the question of product
versus services and and and how do we
how do we take that through this process
and you know broadly speaking products
are usually seed based and services are
usually need-based right so the seed vs
need and the reason why we have this one
year one year process with no team
formation and and and no need to justify
the business plan as long as the massive
problem and to buy the problems
themselves are crafted curated by a
panel of experts and many other people
since that that that need identification
the problem a notification goes through
a very intense process at MIT in in
other places and so on it's all done in
a very public manner but going back to a
question about about products or
services I think if you actually had
that one year and no pressure on on
defining your your business plan then
you'll actually have enough time to
hopefully figure out which way you
should go because products often a push
and service is often a put in terms of
you know the business plan and and so
you know hopefully that that can that
can be taken through that process you
can go to the website to see though it's
a lot of documents and you can go
through the website and also by the
startups are welcome as well to this
platform as long as we are working on a
grand challenge